the vice presidential debate was last  night and it got a significantly smaller  television audience than last week's  presidential debate as you can imagine  clearly it was very hard to get voters  excited about watching Tim Kaine and  Mike Pence you know to fairly unexcited  candidates you know trade quips so each  of the cable news channels tried in  their own way to make the debate a  little more exciting for example CNN  adjusted the audio to keep it more  interesting check this out we cut taxes  we'd record investments in education and  an infrastructure and I still finished  my term with two billion dollars in the  bank PBS  PBS aired the debate with an inset box  featuring spectacular car crashes  yeah and CBS kept cutting away two alive  capoeira demonstration in the debate  hall just to sort of make it a little  more interesting if possible this is  distracting Fox News added a performance  by the Blue Man Group which I didn't  really see the point of that  [Applause]  you